a bold mission to cure cancer just got a
boost from a sophomore in high school at
Bishop Gorman eight new news now
reporter Brian will tells us how this
student was able to raise thousands of
dollars for the Leukemia and Lymphoma
Society with most of the money staying
right here in southern Nevada
and just knowing that helping I was
helping people like that who were
suffering and swatching how it affected
their families and everything was really
important to me and it just felt really
good to know that I was getting back in
any way that I could Talia Higgins a
sophomore at Bishop Gordon never
imagined she would raise 142 thousand
dollars when she embarked upon her
mission to fundraise for the Leukemia
and Lymphoma Society for her it was a
special undertaking like there was two
people in my team that had personal
connections to cancer and and a friend
of mine his little sister was suffering
from cancers highgens with the help of
Ali Amado at the Leukemia and Lymphoma
Society formed a team of students to
raise money we have three pillars that
we put all of our funding into research
patient support and advocacy a lot of
the money that we raise here does stay
here but a lot of it a majority of it
does go into research Huygens and her
team spent seven weeks this spring
visiting businesses across the valley
asking for support when she came across
Phil Ralston of the America Nevada
company they both had raising money for
cancer in common Talia Higgins and her
team raised a hundred and forty two
thousand dollars but she was not alone
all across Southern Nevada the student
Visionaries of the Year raised an
astounding 1.3 million dollars and it's
great when you see
teenagers her age actually get committed
to something that's important
so we kind of bought in Hook Line and
Sinker now she has big plans for next
year my goal is to have more team
members so this year I had a little over
15. so next year I want to try to double
my team member count and then also I
want to double the amount of money
raised